Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
I can't believe she
said No to Dame Judi Dench you
can't say no to her.
So what I'm going to do is my top 5 craziest
Snoke theories talking about Star Wars theories
is so much fun it's even better when their
wildly outlandish one to do a fun bonus video
for Star Wars Fridays.
So there's a new round of the Star Wars giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's for
IMAX gift certificates be sure to click that
bell to enable alerts so you don't miss anything
so I'm just going to start with the less crazy
ones and work my way down to the most crazy
Snoke theories there a bunch of them but I
just tried to pick out five of my favorite,
so number five Snoke is the last Jedi not
Luke Skywalker or Ray like everybody thinks
the two most plausible theories is that the
last Jedi title refers to either the combination
of Ray and Luke.
They are the last of the Jedi is in plural
or is simply referring to Luke the last Jedi
because the opening crawl and episode seven
names him as the last of the Jedi, but the
reason this is my number five is because there
is an element of truth to it.
Like all great theories have a kernel of truth,
no matter how outlandish they sound the idea
that Snoke descends from an order of Jedi
that he is trying to create a new order of
Jedi with Kylo Ren, just suggest that he could
also be the last of the Jedi.
So the only reason I don't think this is going
to pan out.
It just because the theory about Luke and
Ray is a lot more plausible.
So in the face of overwhelming evidence for
another theory is is just on the list of crazy
theories, but is not nearly as nuts is some
of the ones that are low are my list, so number
four Snoke wants to possess Kylo Ren is in
transfer his consciousness in the way that
the Emperor did during the EU.
He had all the clones if you ever read the
dark Empire series is one of the best dark
horse comics Star Wars series ever during
the 90s.
During this period were Star Wars was licensing
out a lot of its book content you got the
throng trilogy there was a lot of great Star
Wars content.
Luke six out the Emperor goes to bis where
this is Darkseid stronghold while he's there.
He learns what happened to the Emperor after
return of the Jedi.
This was the greatest thing for fans to because
your like oh my God there continuing the story
what happened every thrown down the elevator
shaft.
So the idea was that the Emperor is so powerful
that he cannot be out right killed he become
something of a force ghost himself is spirit
transfers into one of his clones.
So it's an 18-year-old version of Emperor
palpitating, but the idea stands that sits
can transfer their consciousness into other's
bodies and take them over.
So along comes been so low this really powerful
Jedi descended from the line of Vader in an
effort to create a more powerful force user
from a fallen light side Jedi who also wields
the dark side of the force, so the theory
is pretty simple that he will build Kylo Ren
up and then use him as a vessel to transfer
himself to because his body is failing.
So much there a couple Snoke theories on this
list that depend on his scars.
The way his body looks how decrepit he is.
How the dark side is twisted him and how he's
going to continue to survive the reason I
think this will pan out is because Snoke himself
is supposed to be somewhat ancient in the
galaxy.
So he's already long-lived he doesn't need
another body, but like I said the reason that
it's plausible is because that act is very
common amongst Darkseid force users really
the only way I think the theory works is if
you feel like the ultimate boss to be defeated
is Snoke and I really feel like it's going
to be a Kylo Ren versus Ray situation is not
can it be like Darth Vader, where he ends
up killing the Emperor at the end something
else will happen it will be a complete repeat
of return of the Jedi number three theory
Snoke is Darth play just slightly more crazy,
but still fairly plausible the reason people
thought this initially is just because he's
a bigger boss to be had and palpitating someone
who's scarier who palpitating try to learn
from the secret of beating death.
So is this really big figure from the Canon
and he's a month, so he resembled what people
thought that Snoke looked like before they
actually saw the movie.
And even after the movie came out because
he was so big the hologram a lot of people
pick that up and ran with it and said okay.
He's just going to be the movie version of
what the months are even though we've seen
them in Star Wars before but this is one of
those theories that people like Pablo Hidalgo
Rian Johnson people behind the cameras have
been trolling fans with just saying your Snoke
theories sucks.
So this is typically what they're referring
to when they say that although their lot of
Snoke theories in the just making fun of that
that I'll explain after my number two because
number two is even crazier number two theory
Snoke is really mace when do I totally love
this theory because it is so crazy Samuel
L Jackson's ears are burning like he just
sits up somewhere wherever he's sitting in
the world right now listening to everyone
talk about hell yeah want to come back to
Star Wars.
This theory largely depended on him.
Surviving his encounter with palpitating and
episode three in becoming scarred in the way
that Snoke is scarred being twisted to the
dark side of the force is sort of slinking
away to come back and haunt the galaxy in
this physical form with the first-order and
Kylo Ren the problem with this in the reason
that the producers like to make fun of fans
so much which is sometimes it's funny sometimes
it's not so funny just because I think what's
really going on with Snoke's identity is that
they wanted to create a brand-new character
that wasn't somebody from the Canon that they
didn't necessarily overly explain early on,
so a lot of people were trying to fill the
gaps like if you such a big figure why have
we heard about them before, and I think the
simple explanation for that is that they don't
want to reveal too much information about
them.
They wanted to be mysterious.
So he is a big figure in the history of the
galaxy, but the only reason you haven't heard
about him in the other expanded materials
is because they haven't written that yet they
haven't edited that in the way that they added
that death Star McGuffin during Rogue one
like this is the reason for that glaring error
in design of the death Star, so the gonna
be some moments like that in the new films
that will explain why we haven't seen Snoke
before.
So even though I love the amazing Snoke is
secretly someone else theories.
I don't think they're going to pan out, but
my number one craziest theory, which is even
more outlandish is is that Snoke created Ray
in a lab like she's secretly a test tube baby
that was engineered by Snoke to be this new
vessel.
So the main reason why that probably isn't
going to pan out you can already imagine is
is because he didn't seem to immediately know
exactly who she was, he just knew there was
an awakening in the force, so her parents
will be someone else in there have been a
lot of new theories recently about who her
parents are a lot of people think that it
might be Benicia Del Toro as an older version
of Ezra Bridger because he's going to be a
villain in the new films and we haven't seen
a whole lot of rebels.
We don't know where Ezra is in all these new
films are happening, but I might do another
video about that next week.
I don't think it's going to pan out either
but it's actually a really good theory.
So let me know in the comments what are your
favorite crazy Star Wars episode eight theories
or they could be for episode nine just the
more outlandish the better even if you don't
think they're going to pan out.
Just write them below in the comments what
I'm going to do next is is him and oppose
my Lego Batman Easter egg video there's a
bunch new footage from Logan the drop.
So I'll be posting updates on the video schedule
as I post new videos that Lego Batman Easter
eggs will post Saturday morning.
Congratulations to Flare knight you're the
latest Star Wars giveaway winner he went to
IMAX gift certificates.
Please private message me on the back and
my channel so I can get your contact details.
So there's a new round that started in this
video I'll announce the winner the next time
I post of Star Wars video while you wait for
that you can click here to learn all about
Snoke's Backstory that's actually Canon to
Star Wars and you can click here to learn
about the new Iron Man suit.
We might see during.
Spider-Man homecoming, thank you so much watching
everbody high five and I'll see in the next
video!